I texted your brother I said hey I'm
about to record with your brother and he
goes he got progressively more truthful
he goes tell him I said hi then he goes
tell him I said honor the Ali name then
he goes and tell him to
stop that was his his
advice so yeah I've delivered the
[Music]
message
all right we have um Moy Ali here you've
been on the Pod before uh people know
you because you created native deodorant
which is sold everywhere I look in
Target online in my wife's bathroom it's
there everywhere so congrats you built
that you bootstrapped that business
yourself uh literally like off of a
kitchen table to1 million exit to
Proctor and Gamble you spent a couple
years there you currently uh you invest
in a bunch of Comm Merce things and
non-commerce things you have a podcast
called limited Supply which is great and
then you um you also do you you and your
brother are sort of like business sharks
and so uh you know if I just say hey
there's like a there's a hot dog stand
going out of business over here you'd be
like let me get my jacket let's go uh
you own real estate you own a bunch of
random things and so always fun to have
you on man uh thanks for coming well
thanks for having me super excited to be
here is that the intro you want by the
way or do you feel like I let I didn't
do you justice in one angle uh no that
sounds that sounds like uh more Justice
than I deserve well you're also good at
on lines uh you have a lot of like on
liners you're you're very good with
language you um you've said a few things
you said my two favorite words in the
English English language distressed
asset and then one time we were talking
to this person it was you and me and
this person and they were explaining
what they do and it was like a
supplement company and how great it was
going to be and how they're raising all
this money and she she or them or he
whatever walked out the room and you
said that person's business is one
Google away from me ruining
it yeah you have a couple other Classics
uh I read an interview with you where it
where you said uh you said I forgot you
phrased it you go I was put on Earth to
do one thing raise earnings per share
earnings per share yeah that wasn't me
that said that actually it was the
founder of some other company I forgot
what it was and it was such a great
quote I loved it so I stole that qu yeah
you're like I killed him and now it's
mine that's right yeah yeah the other
one that I I I attribute to you I didn't
I wasn't there for this story but I've
told this story to like hundreds of
young entrepreneurs and they get a kick
out of every time which is like yeah
Moyes started native deodorant it's
super successful now and when he first
had the idea he told people I'm going to
create a natural deodorant brand they're
like Moyes like do you know anything
about deodorant do you wear deodorant
boys what's going on what are you
talking about you're going to create a
deodorant company and you said um yeah I
know nothing about deodorant today but
in 6 months I'll know everything there
is to know about deodorant and that
that's right that attitude to me is like
that's the core of what we do on this
podcast so I don't even know if that's a
real story by the way but I'm going to
keep telling it that's a real story I
remember it was in San Francisco I was
with one of my law school classmates and
it was her boyfriend of the time our
husband who told me that and he's like
uh you know what the hell are you doing
here
he worked at Pinterest and he's like
what the hell are you doing starting a
deodor business I've never heard anybody
do something so ludicrous and I still
remember the bar we were sitting at
where it happened all right so let's do
a little segment that I'm gonna call
Story Time with Moy Ali so okay uh to
the music okay so I'm gonna ask you a
question I want you to give me your
answer boys what is the um what what is
the worst way that you've ever made
money yeah uh you know this is um uh
this is a great story I think we uh we
don't tell enough or my brother and I
don't tell enough which is when we were
growing up we owned gas stations and
this is really a family way we made
money and not my particular way anyway
we owned a bunch of gas stations and we
would cash checks for people as a
service so if you brought in a check uh
Sean and you're like hey look this is my
payroll check it's $200 for this week or
$2,000 for this week we would charge you
a percentage of that check and give you
cash for it and we would take the check
and deposit it into the bank and um by
the end of our gas station careers we
were doing this at massive scale like uh
one of our stores would cash $250,000
wor of checks on any given Friday like a
quarter million dollars of cash was
going through our hands we'd have like
Wells SPO coming over and giving us cash
um and you know we'd be giving it like
you know we have these crazy like a Bus
full of Hispanic immigrants who are
roofers would come to our store the door
would open and like it felt like 40
immigrants just came out to cash their
checks with us
but a long time ago like what happened
early on in our check cashing careers
was this guy named FM Porter who came in
with a check for his business and the
check was like you know $2,000 and we
charged a lot because I don't remember
why we charged a lot but we gave him
like $1,900 we charged 5% of the check
and we were going to deposit the check
and earn
$2,000 um and you know traditionally
what happens is if you're cashing a
check this doesn't happen so much
anymore but it used to happen 15 years
ago you'd endorse the back of it and
you'd deposit it at the bank right so
endorsed the back of it we gave him the
$1900 we deposited it and it bounced and
we're like what the [__] uh this is a
ton of money for us uh you know we were
poor immigrants we were working at this
gas station probably in 1997 earning
$40,000 a year with all five of us
working at the how old were you uh I was
probably like 13 at the time 12 or 13 at
the time and like this was going on so
there's just are you is I just imagine
like 13-year-old Moyes like pacing
smoking aars be like what the [__]
man
like is that what it looked like I mean
just like I I imagine you being the
exact same way as you are now when you
were 12 well yeah I feel like I was the
same way but I didn't have as much
confidence so I couldn't take the cigar
I couldn't order people around but
anyway the check bounced and we all
freaked out and uh we tracked down this
guy uh and we're like what the [__] we
knocked on his door I forgot what he Liv
he lived in like a small house OB like
you know it was just local community we
knocked down his door we're like what
the [__] FM Porter this check just cash
we're going to kill you we're going to
call the cops we don't know what to do
we're broke down uh give us our money
and he was like relax guys there's a pro
like you know the check was made out to
his business instead of him and so it
took like 45 days uh to figure out all
the riger roll to get the check made out
to him instead of to uh his business and
then we cashed it and we uh deposited
the money and I remember it went through
the second time you know we made $100 on
45 days of you know possibly losing
$2,000 and I remember it went through
and I told my brother hey it went
through and he's like that was the
easiest $100 we've ever made and I
remember it was like the worst $100
we've ever made it was just cashing
checks that were going bad and
constantly being afraid that they were
like this this was early on in our
career we weren't sure if we should do
this as a service for our business it
ended up being super profitable like
when you cash $250,000 of checks on a
Friday you're going to make $2500 to
$3,500 on that just for your business on
that day alone but I remember early on
we were taking all these risks and we
were like what just happened we think
that like you know we're not going to be
able to pay our rent for the apartment
that my family lives in that's insane
were you just going back to like math
class after your shift or like how were
you were you going after school what was
your how did you do this oh to the gas
station you mean yeah cuz you're like 13
years old yeah yeah we'd go on the
weekends like uh cuz you know we like um
yeah we'd go the weekends when I turned
16 I could drive and I would go you know
yeah after class class or like on the
weekends I wouldn't go every day uh even
when I was 16 years old but I'd probably
go at least one weekend or maybe both
weekends of the uh uh when I started
having a car
certainly our software is the worst have
you heard of HubSpot see most crms are a
cobble together mess but HubSpot is easy
to adopt and actually looks gorgeous I
think I love our new CRM our software is
the best HubSpot grow better we're in
the story we're in the story uh part of
the show so let me ask you one thing
that I don't know is true but I want you
to confirm it so right by our office the
one that you and I shared there was a
cafe called native coffee I think it was
it was the native Cafe native juice
native juice native juice it had the
same color and the same logo as native
deodorant did you it it was right by the
B stop I believe so if I'm imagining
what happened you went on you were on
BART and you were just walking around s
and you saw it and you go there it is
that's mine now is that true true or
false
sub that's false not it's not false I'll
tell the story we got to put the picture
up because they're identical it's an
identical I actually think they changed
their branding in the last three years
but you could still find old logos on
their yel page yeah so the uh it's a
little funnier like it was actually a
block away from where I lived um so I'd
walk by it all the time but uh you know
the color I'm not sure if the color was
the same I know the font was the same uh
we actually didn't steal the font from
them although I readily admit we did
steal the font we stole the font of our
website from Harry's so if you look at
Harry's font it's the exact same font as
ours and if you look at the colors of
our site it was and I'm not sure if it
still is the exact same color as the
Casper hat so like you know when I was
launching native it took me about you
know three days to do the whole website
and I was just like okay you know what
I'm not going to do is hire a logo
designer and spend a fortune building a
logo and spending a lot of money on
branding i l steal the logo that Harry's
has which is just their name written out
in a font I'm going to do the same thing
uh I can't steal their colors as well
because that would be too too blatant uh
so I'm just going to steal the colors of
another website which was Casper at the
time because they were doing really well
and so that's how the uh that's how the
font and the colors came together to be
what Native is today um but I I would
walk by that store all the time and like
believe it or not right next to Native
Juco is the post office and I was
packing all of the deodorants in my own
apartment uh for the first six months or
a year of the business and so I would
walk by native Juco with these bags of
like you know filled with boxes of
deodorant and I'd go to the Post Office
and I'd hand them to the post office and
they were like is this from next door is
this like the juice company you guys it
says native on the packaging and I was
like this is not the same native it's a
different one and then what would happen
is like you know two and a half years
into the business native juiceco came
like the woman who started that business
came to her office and she's like I'm
getting so many [__] phone calls for
your business for customer service
issues where's my package all this [__]
people are just Googling native San
Francisco we didn't have a phone number
we I think Native still doesn't have a
phone number posted so she would be like
I'm getting 40 phone calls a day for you
this has got to stop you got to figure
out a way to stop this and we're like we
can't we don't know what to do like you
know people just Google native San
Francisco and your name comes up it's
not we're not saying call you and so she
came in like several times and then um
you know I was like I told the DOR men
of the building I was like don't let her
up any longer and that seem to put it
into
it if she has juice accept it but don't
let her yeah that's
right we would still order juice from
her to our office all the time but I was
like I'm not sure if they like this or
not yeah definely Rin definitely drink a
lot of her spin I have to
imagine yeah that's probably true too
yeah but the reality is we like um the
logo didn't come from native Juco it
came from Harry's she just happened to
also copy the Harry's logo that's what
she might have done the same thing
that's right yeah yeah all right so you
said you had some ideas for us um what
business ideas do you have on your brain
right now um okay I I thought about a
lot of these ideas for a while um I
think the first idea that someone should
start if I if I were starting a business
today and really excited about it i'
would start with a stock market for all
residential real estate I would say okay
I'm going to start buying residential
real estate and you know selling shares
of that real estate that's rented out so
i' buy rental homes and I would sell
shares of that real estate sort of like
a traditional LP would invest but I'd
make a really liquid Market on my site
so I'd say you know what rents have gone
up you paid $110,000 you're waiting for
us to sell this home it'll like you know
if you buy an apartment building today
if you're an LP in an apartment building
you're waiting for the GP to sell the
apartment building before you get you
can realize all your cash back you might
be getting a steady stream of income
every quarter but when the GP sells the
apartment building that's where you get
most of your money back I just create a
liquid market for all of these things
and I would slowly start buying every
single house in a neighborhood and I
would say you can only buy and sell
shares of this house on this platform uh
and then what I would do is I would
Empower local entrepreneurs to buy and
sell houses on the platform themselves
too I'd say okay you know what sea is
going to buy a house he lives in this
neighborhood in in California he can buy
a house put it on this platform raise
money and buy and sell and other people
can buy and sell shares of this house
through this platform and then Shawn
will get reviews just like on Amazon and
like if he does a really good job people
will give him festar reviews because
they're getting a lot of money from him
if he does a really shitty job people
will give him onear reviews because he's
doing a really shitty job and then when
you go to underwrite New Deals people
will be like sea is trustworthy Shawn is
not trustworthy and I think people have
tried this in the past with things like
realy shares and a bunch of other shitty
models of this and I think they've done
a terrible job in part because they're
not doing a good job underwriting in
part they're doing it uh they're they're
betting on Commercial properties um and
in part because they're not creating a
liquid market for it and so I think that
um when I think of like the biggest idea
possible I think that this idea could
realistically own you know 200 years
from now this business should own the
majority of real estate in the United
States uh so let's break that down so
you said sure the reason that the
current kind of like bu a fraction of uh
you know of real estate or buy shares in
real estate which there's several or
crowdfunding for Real Estate there's
like fund rise realy shares you're
saying the problems that they have is uh
let's take them one by one so you said
they're focused on Commercial why is
residential better than commercial for
this uh way easier in terms of steady
income streams So like um if you build
if let's say you buy a building that
Starbucks is using and has a 5-year
lease on when Starbucks leaves that
building it's unclear who will be a good
fit for that building like it's not easy
to rent that thing out while if it's a
house everyone in the world needs a
three-bedroom two bath house uh in a
neighborhood and so it's a lot easier to
relet properties that are residential as
opposed to commercial I invested in the
company uh somewhat in the space it was
called dorsy it was um it didn't work
out but the guy who started it
previously started stay Alfred which I
don't know if you remember that one or
not but basically you could it was like
it was an auction website for homes and
there they had two issues one it which
is I'm shocked by this but people just
didn't want to buy a home online it was
just like a big it was a it was a big
thing that they couldn't figure out how
to address uh I think someone will
figure it out but the second thing was
negotiating the whole broker industry
which like it seems like the broker
industry I know there was just like a
big settlement like five days ago the
broker industry has like has this
industry by the balls it seems uh it's
really it seems really challenging yeah
and it wasn't a settlement it was a jury
verdict of $2 billion that went against
the National Association of Realtors
like yeah yeah and so like yes the I
think the broker industry is broken but
the the like the liquidity market for
real estate investing is huge and when
you think about it like you know all
these retail investors are now like let
me invest in a startup you know how
crazy it is for for you to invest in
like native when it's early on like I
have no [__] idea what I'm doing I
don't know if I'm going to get hit by a
bus tomorrow I might just be like [__]
it you know what like uh I'm dating this
crazy girl and she wants to go to Hawaii
for three months [__] this this is going
to be way this is going to be way more
fun than running a business for the next
three months so uh investing in like if
you're can invest in startups what like
you know you know it's way safer than
investing in a startup investing in real
estate down your street where you're
like I know who's going to rent this
house I I like you know I can monitor it
I can drive bu it it's a tangible piece
of property like you know if this guy
doesn't pay rent somebody else will it's
not going anywhere it's way safer and I
think when I when I think of retail
investors I think retail investors would
be way more excited about investing in
the local community they live in and
being like yeah I own a share of this
house than they do being like I invested
in this Pakistani guy who really likes
and he seems not to be that
reliable and so you you have like uh
this idea why do you think that the
person who's buying these rental props
properties wants to do this just because
they want the liquidity so they can go
buy more properties uh like what what
happens here and how much of the
property you think would go on the
platform versus they own you know like
would they like in an IPO you know they
they issue 20% of their stock or
whatever to the public what would you
what would it be for the house yeah I
think it's really the GP can be like
look I want to like the guy who's sort
of underwriting the deal and sponsoring
the deal for better or for uh worse is
could be like look I'm going to put in
this house cost $200,000 I'm going to
put in $50,000 in my own money or I'm
going to put in $20,000 in my own money
and in that same way that other like
right now if you invest in a much larger
if you invest in a private Equity Fund
one of the common questions you'll ask
is the guys who are running the private
Equity Fund how much of their own money
is at risk because that means that they
care and believe in their private Equity
Fund similarly here could be the same
question how much of your wealth or or
how much investment are you putting in
this real estate when you uh purchase it
and the reason that the sponsors would
want to do this is several fold one is
yeah they want to create a liquid Market
they want to raise money right like they
want to raise money from retail
investors and it's really hard to raise
money from retail investors uh two is
they can buy and sell shares of later on
for themselves as well they could be
like you know what I bought $440,000
worth of this house 5 years later that
40,000 is worth 80,000 I want some cash
off the table but I still want some
liquidity I'm going to sell $40,000 of
shares uh in this house and keep some uh
money in invested as well so I think for
the same reason that people want to
invest in the stock market or uh you
know sponsors uh in their own deals uh
you know sponsors in this would invest
as well so Moyes I'm going to pit you
three other real estate ideas in Rapid
succession I want you to tell me your
favorite to your least favorite okay all
right uh the first one is this company I
didn't invest in but I reg I reget I
don't know how it's doing I haven't
talked to the guy in a while but I I
regret not investing because I I thought
it was a good idea it's called home
options so what he's doing is this guy
goes to uh Sam Sam owns a house he goes
to Sam and says Sam I know you're not
trying to sell the house right now but
here's the deal um I'll give you $11,200
right now and all I ask for is that when
you do decide to sell um you let me you
know I own the option to be the broker
on the house so like you know I'll be
your agent and uh and actually what I do
is I'm not myself the agent but I
partner with top agents in your network
and they don't know when you're going to
sell your house and they don't want to
keep having a knock on your door and
bother you so I'll give you cash today
so that they can be your bro you know
and one of these top agents gets the
right to be your broker 20 years from
now whenever you sell and um they're
just buying up options uh the the right
to sell these homes because a home when
you sell you know the Brokers take let's
just say let's just say the sell side's
going to take 3% um you know they're
they're let's say the average is $15,000
or something for that for that sale
they're willing to buy that option today
for $1,000 and so uh that's idea number
one home options going going through and
buying that uh all right idea number two
is y I invested in it
fck the only thing that could have made
me feel worse about not investing in
this is that Sam invested in this is it
doing well because I I every like three
months I think about this business I
think that's got a k I went through my
email and I haven't gotten an update
from them in like a while so that's not
a good sign yeah which unfortunately
means it's probably not or it's
absolutely crushing it one of the two um
you know I I used to think that's always
a bad sign but then I started hanging
out with moy's brother and he never he's
like investor update why would I I'm
going to kill it in this business why
should I tell you about how it's going I
need to know this yeah that's right yeah
are you that way too Moy do do you like
do you provide updates or one of our
investors was this guy named Jeff
Hollander from Seventh Generation and
he's like you know what would be nice is
like a monthly or quarterly investment
update and I was like here's your money
back I'm you know you I you and I will
never chat until I call you uh and if
you're not okay with that I don't ever
yeah yeah I like I was like I couldn't
care like I will never send you one
piece of information about this business
unless I want to unless I need something
for you you think it's good good hygiene
to like you know just kind of even for
your own thoughts to be like how are we
doing what's a let me take a step back
here for a second and just write down
kind of for my own Clarity of thought or
no um I think that is good hygiene but I
don't think you necessarily have to
share that with other people especially
with other people like you know um I
think the three of us are probably
investors in similar businesses and you
know often times I walk around and
people are like here are the numbers of
this other business and I'm like you
know somebody has leaked it to them and
I'm I try to be really careful as an
investor to never leak information
because I know I would never want my
information leaked but like that
information gets around the street and
uh I you know I've seen so many startups
launch because they're like I heard this
guy was doing really well so I should
just do the same thing like how many
competitors of athletic greens exist
because everyone's like yeah we know
athletic greens is doing really well
what are the other two Sean all right
second second idea this is your
brother's idea actually I don't know if
he told you this one um pipe for Real
Estate so uh I think I could share this
now because he he's talks about this
like I don't a year ago and didn't end
up doing it um pipe for Real Estate the
idea here is uh you're a landlord you're
gonna collect rent every month uh pipe
came through and was like hey let me
turn those uh monthly checks into one
annual check and I'll take a 8% fee off
the top so let's say you were going to
get 100 Grand of rent from this property
um I'll give you 92,000 today I get to
keep the 100 um and you get you get
92,000 that you can go invest in your
next property you or or put into tenant
improvements that will let you raise
rents or something like that here's cash
flow today upfront so pipe for Real
Estate uh real estate's a huge Market uh
why why do landlords have to wait to
collect the check um no more waiting is
our slogan all right now idea number
three final idea uh I did invest in this
one so steady Capital so steady. capital
is their their URL so they were like hey
look everybody knows that most will most
millionaires build their wealth through
real estate that's that is a Time tested
you know approach to wealth building um
most people actually even want to they
would love to own a rental property and
be getting a rent check every month but
most people don't know don't trust
themselves to find a property you know
vet it buy it manage it all of that and
so they were like we'll do a Robin Hood
for Real Estate type of thing where you
just decide how much L you want to put
into real estate you say I'm willing to
put away $500 a month into real estate
and they basically let you take the 500
bucks they'll put it into a real estate
project that they are kind of vetting uh
from like proven uh operators and then
they every month they'll say hey here's
an you know you got $112 of you know
rental income from your property this
month yeah uh or you you now own you
know pieces of these six properties in
six different markets and you're making
$600 a month of rental income like I I
put five grand into one deal and I just
get this check every month now and it's
actually the first real estate that I've
done that I didn't own because otherwise
it just stayed on my too list all right
so those are the three ideas home
options pipe for real estate and
Robinhood for yeah the yeah steady
Capital um give me rank them from your
most favorite to your least favorite go
ahead okay I I I wasn't like I was
expecting uh home options would be
number three when you told me about it
but in fact it's number one uh steady
capital and then Pet For Real Estate uh
and I'll tell you why um pipe for Real
Estate exists and it's just called a
cash out refi like you know that already
exists where you're like look I'm
getting real you know I'm getting money
from these landlord uh from these
tenants and I can take cash off the uh
out of the property like you know what's
not going to happen for pipe for Real
Estate is someone's going to come in and
be like wow you're 100% levered up with
this debt let me also give you more cash
uh you already paying for the debt you
know you're already levered uh so I
think pipe for Real Estate exists uh and
I think you know Mark lore started this
company and he just raised $350 million
did you guys read this thing uh I'm not
entirely sure what it is but it appears
to be like a restaurant delivery
business uh where he partners with like
you know F think that's right yeah yeah
and um so I feel like I'm not sure if
this is the case but it seems like that
sort of like a a startup branding to
something that kind of exists in in this
space I feel like pipe for Real Estate
is the same Mark bought Blue Apron oh he
bought Blue Apron I knew they sold for
$12 million I didn't know he was the
cash behind it yeah he bought it yeah so
he is I think you're you've nailed it
that sounds like that's what he's doing
but go ahead yeah um home options is
like you know I think the hard part
about home options is right now like
particularly in the last week right now
we don't know what real commissions are
going to look like in the future and you
also just don't know how long an option
this is is the $1,200 in the ground
today for 20 years or 30 years that's a
really long period of time forance I
think what he's doing is he's just
reselling it right away or at least
that's what I would do is I would buy
the option I would bundle them up and I
would go sell them to The Brokerage
tomorrow you know and just say hey you
you can hold these and you know I try
try to get I don't know if the economics
all work I don't know if the Brokers are
willing to do things like that yeah but
like I think that's the idea yeah I like
it it's Innovative and like different
and un like you know unclear what'll
happen but like you could revolutionize
an industry that you know has been the
same for the last 150 years God damn it
Sam's going to be a part of that
Revolution it could also be the 6% drops
down to 2% in the next you know 3 months
because you the National Association of
real is almost certainly bankrupt at
this point what was the settlement and
what's changing about this broker
situation yeah wasn't a settlement it
was2 billion I'm not entirely sure what
what it was it was like price fixing
across Realtors uh basically saying hey
you can't be on MLS unless you agree to
pay everyone like a 6% or 5% brokerage
something to that effect I haven't
gotten into the details of it but like
the Judgment was $2 billion and I read
this Wall Street Journal article where
once the Judgment was had uh plaintiff
sperms you know file lawsuits against
the National Association of realizers in
every single state and they're like we
think that we'll get $40 billion in
judgments as a result of this which will
certainly bankr up that organization can
you talk a little bit about this
Founders card thing because I've know
you've been tweeting about that for like
two years now and I'm and that actually
surprised me that you were interested in
it you know there's I feel like there's
uh there's a a a club that I'm a part of
or like a Founders card sort of thing
that I'm a part of that I can't talk
about the the name of it because they
would ask me not to but with like as a
result of paying my $100 a month um and
monthly uh membership fee I get a
discount that's worth like you know $800
a month to myself what do you get a
discount for just sta software that I'm
like uh really want that I have to pay
for but do you have to be a new C A lot
of those cards you have to be a new
customer no this one you don't yeah wow
you just pay $100 a month and they're
like here's discounts to like let's say
mailchip and let's say Shopify and like
all these other SAS platforms that an
e-commerce company might want to be a
part of or might want discounts too and
so then you go and say great I paid $100
I get all these discounts and I'm going
to go use those discounts for um for for
for for my business and so you never are
going to cancel that $100 a month
subscription because that $100 is
actually saving you $1,000 a month and
um I don't understand why there aren't
more of these for smaller Niche
Industries and I think like e-commerce
is a great one like uh you know what PNG
does they go and they uh they go to like
Snapchat and Pinterest and Facebook and
they say look we're going to spend 50 m
$250 million across our portfol folio on
your platform but we need a discount
because you know we're spending so much
money and they get that discount they
get it from Facebook for sure because
I've seen it I'm pretty sure Pinterest
and I'm pretty sure Snapchat but I
guarantee you they get a Facebook a
discount for Facebook because I've seen
it I you know I saw when I was running
native as a part of PNG and so I'm not
sure why smaller businesses don't
organize and say look we're spending
this much let us also try and negotiate
discounts with platforms why don't we
all negotiate a discount with yappo or
with Endo or with post scpt or with
clavo and say look there's going to be
400 of us together a lot of us are going
to use this software but we need a big
discount that's a lifetime that's a like
a lifetime monthly recurring discount
and so sorry you have one of these this
is not an idea you're saying you have
one of these cards but you're saying you
it's like a secret like you don't uh
they don't they don't want more people
to have the card or what correct they
would not want me to talk about who they
are but yes as a result I get discounts
to software that I wouldn't get
otherwise and cost me1 or $140 a month
why don't they want to talk about it
yeah great question I'm not entirely
sure but I'm sure they would tell me not
to talk
about you think $100 months well like
there's more a spidey some spoty s is
going off here uh you know like what's
going on why I mean is this a shady
thing Sam this was this was your idea um
like uh you not your idea originally but
like Sam told I mean I don't know seven
years ago when you were running the
hustle you were like I'm trying to think
of a new product and you had three ideas
and I remember one of them was basically
Trends which is the thing you ended up
launching another one was uh this idea
for the founders Club card or whatever
which was I think you were comparing it
to the AARP you're like ARP for kind of
like Millennials or and I can talk about
that ARP in a second but yeah that was
uh the second one what was the third one
you had you had one more I don't
remember that third one but and I
thought the card was the best idea I was
like oh you should for sure do this card
if I had this and in fact actually now
I'm just going to do the card off of the
MFM audience because I'm like this is
way better and it's a
win-win I might be a few months ahead of
you why didn't you do that card the
reason why I didn't was I couldn't find
uh I couldn't figure out entirely how to
differentiate from all the other
offerings that already existed um it was
also quite challenging to get in with
some of the brands in order to negotiate
bulk deals the argument being well you
know these companies already spend with
us why am I going to give them a
discount and I couldn't come up with
like the perfect rebuttal for that and
that like that is where I I was trying
to figure out how to make it happen and
what is the rebuttal to that the ble for
that is your competitors are offering it
right so you basically have to go get
the number two of every space and say
hey we can move you some customers if
you make this attractive and then you go
back to number one you say hey number
two is offering this and they people are
moving um you should match it yeah and
like new people who get get in are going
to use number two instead of number one
because they get the discount EX exactly
exactly and we we continue to have new
customers and we're just going to keep
telling them go with this company
because they offer you know a benefit
and the reason why I was interested in
it is AARP so AARP uh I actually don't
know what it stands for but it's a club
for people above 60 or 50 I think 50
American Association of retired persons
yeah retired so I guess it's 60 um they
do about1 and a half to2 billion dollar
a year in sales and they have millions
and millions and millions and millions
of members the way they make business is
uh revenue is I think they only charge
about $100 a year to be a member and
like most everyone when you turn 60 you
get an an invitation in your mail and
what you do is you get discounted health
insurance and they make uh another side
of their business is making money it's a
basically an affiliate feed so I think
they parted with United Health and they
have the United Health AARP Plan which
is discounted plan but also a plan
specifically for whatever you know 60
plus people have uh and they are I think
one of the largest lobbying groups in
America it's a huge lobbying group they
they they basically uh like kind of
shaped the government in in some regard
and so I thought that was super
fascinating it's a really fascinating
company that's existed for decades and
isn't going to go away anytime soon and
there's already other businesses doing
this like think about why combinator
when you get into why combinator I think
they're like you get you know $250,000
of AWS credits you get a bunch of like
stripe processing charges for free and
like those businesses are like you're
going to grow we're going to make money
at the end uh but it also makes like you
know when Y combinator is selling you on
giving you $120,000 for 7% they're also
like here are the other benefits that
you get in this business right um so
anyway I'm on board with this you want
to do one more yeah what's the other
idea you had something around Shopify
for high-end or something for highend D
what was that idea yeah sure um you know
uh Shopify is fantastic I'm a big
shareholder in Shopify I love them you
know I built my career on in e-commerce
uh the reality is it's wonderful for
businesses going from Z to $50 million
it's awful for businesses it's not awful
but it's not good for businesses north
of $100 million that are ready to spend
a lot more on improving their conversion
rate on a custom checkout page and you
know the Shopify people were here they
if the Shopify people were on this
podcast with me they'd say that's crazy
we have big businesses like figs and all
birds and uh a lot of other big
businesses on it but the reality is
there's so many lack Like You Can't
customize so much and it's so difficult
particularly on the checkout page that I
think there is room for somebody to come
in and say I'm going to build my own
shop I'm to build Shopify but for
businesses doing North of100 billion and
there's a lot of businesses doing north
of $100 billion that have left Shopify
you know Away Travel ritual Vitamins
because they're like look we've outgrown
this platform where did they go probably
like usually a custombuilt stack
sometimes with like this backbone of an
old brand of an old business called
spree which I think was like this open-
Source e-commerce platform when you were
growing your business but I don't think
it's around anymore uh but I like you
know they'll often go to their own
custom Tech platform because they're
like look we're doing enough business
that this makes sense which is a pain in
the ass it is a pain in the ass but like
you know it's a pain in the ass is worth
it when you're doing $500 million in
revenue and a quarter you know quarter
percentage Point bump in conversion rate
on your checkout page is going to lead
to an extra 1020 million in Revenue it's
it's it's it's completely worth it then
and um you know like shopify's one one
page checkout like they launched that in
the last six months that's been
something that people have wanted for a
really long time Shopify subscriptions
has been really bad like all the
subscription platforms have been really
bad until more recently so I think shopi
is trying to catch up on that larger uh
segment but I think they've done that
that's not their focus their focus is
you've decided you want to start a
business you go you know in the shower
you come downstairs and you start a
Shopify store that business is doing
aund million in Revenue you know there
are solutions that are competitive where
more competitive than Shopify is uh and
they're worth it because small changes
in your website are going to be worth so
much and they're harder to do in Shopify
than they are to do in other brand yeah
candidly like you know native was a $50
million e-commerce business built on
WordPress and the reason we did
WordPress was because it was cheap way
cheaper and because it allowed us a lot
more customization we could do post-p
purchase pop-ups it at toar pop-ups at a
time where we couldn't on Shopify we
could do subscriptions that didn't
charge us AR L to have subscriptions
that you still can't do on Shopify uh
you know we could have our own servers
which you know you may or may not want
based on Shopify we could do
instantaneous page loading which you
couldn't do on Shopify and so there were
a lot of benefits for a business for
because it was open source versus
Shopify yeah you use the uh $300 a year
woo Commerce which is like the steal of
the century and the my of the century
for WordPress it's $300 it's free it's
free is it free yeah I mean I used it
too I thought it yeah you know all those
features that he just said were benefits
uh that's not why he did it to be clear
he picked it cuz he was like $33,000 for
Shopify outrageous Over My Dead Body I
would rather this business fail than pay
you $3,000 had a business I was doing
Millions a year and we used woocommerce
and I remember it's owned by WordPress
now I think and I remember like looking
at wordpress's Revenue I'm like okay so
WordPress controls a third of the
internet and Shopify makes this much
money and yet they're giving this to me
what a bunch of idiots you guys like
like you're it's a massive missed
opportunity for WordPress and woocomerce
is great you just need a developer
sometimes to help you do some stuff but
it's still way cheaper than Shopify
that's right but like really it just
goes to like you know we could we did a
post-p purchase popup at dative which
was after you clicked checkout we showed
you a popup saying buy travel siiz
deodorant we probably sold $700,000 of
those traviz deodorant every single
month uh and made you know $400,000 in
net profit off those Travis siiz
deodorants uh and we could only do that
in WordPress we could not do that in
Shopify you uh you also had something
you were like I would do uh Shopify apps
for India or something and I found this
interesting because our Shopify app bill
now granted I could go through and prune
some apps that we're not using anymore
that are probably still just recurringly
charging me but I think we spend like 10
Grand a month on Shopify addons do you
really it's insane because whatever you
want to do they're like oh would you
like to collect email
addresses well pay me $1,500 a month
like for this popup like what are you
talking about and they're like well your
store is big and it's like that doesn't
matter this is an email popup who what
do you care how many people type into
the form like Google forms is free what
what are you talking about and like um
every little thing like we added a um
postp purchase upsell and it was like
$900 a month and I was like what's
happening why why would would this be so
expensive um all the review platforms
are crazy expensive shopy apps are you
know an absolute like rip off in the
pricing definitely and and I think that
you know if I were if I were a developer
in India I'd be like I'm gonna hire a
team of you guys we're going to knock
off every single app and we're going to
charge $20 a month and that's going to
be our entire business model is $20 a
month and like you know the other thing
I'd say is the more apps you use the
cheaper it gets so if you're using five
apps instead of paying $100 you're
paying $75 get the you know like there
is no reason that just Doo popups should
be $1,500 a month there's no reason that
a post-p purchase upsell should be a
percentage of Revenue and not $30 a
month and uh the reality is that
everyone's tiered percentages of Revenue
because you can make so much money doing
that and this is software that like you
know could have been written within a
week or a week and a half by almost
anybody um and should be $30 a month I
talked to a guy I tried to buy this one
Shopify app that um all it did was it
added a Max maximum to your cart like a
feature people don't even think it's
like why would I ever stop someone from
buying more and it's like H let's say
you're doing like a limited edition
thing you don't want like the resellers
to go buy all your [__] and uh these
guys you know for for like seven years
they've been doing like two million a
year with a million dollar a million and
a half dollars of
profit just on one Shopify app that just
caps the maximum somebody could could
buy of a of a unit and that that's got
to be like you know that should be like
two lines of code or something it's
crazy uh but there are so many of these
that that exist out there and people
have smartly tried to roll some of these
up yeah and how many of those how many
of customers of that app are probably
customers who don't look at their bill
on every a monthly basis and they're
like oh man I'm getting charged $200 a
month and I never think about it yeah
yeah because it's tot it's built first
you never whip out your credit card you
just once you connect to Shopify it's
gonna pay you through Shopify and then
it's buried in the billing tab under all
this stuff so yeah there's definitely uh
there's like low very low friction in
like racking up those charges there's a
massive business to be built here which
is cloning the top 100 Shopify apps and
just charging a flat fee like you know
it might be a longer term business
because you don't have a sales team and
you're not going out calling everyone
being like switch from you know yappo to
me but it is a every single new business
is going to go to you because it's way
easier to use you have some
controversial opinions you have a lot of
them um a few of them data is overrated
wealth managers are just used car
salesmen you uh hate real Twitter real
estate I want to hear some thoughts on
on those things we'll start with um
we'll start with an easy one of data
being overrated what what do you mean by
that um let's start with an easier one
which is uh Twitter real estate mind um
like uh wait say say the unpopular
opinion what is it about Twitter real
estate uh it's full of complete [__]
they're full of frauds and they're like
I can't begin to tell you how many
people where I like read their tweets
some deals I'm in and I'm like you how
is nobody calling you out on this like
um you know people are like are
give give the listener perspective here
so you
own maybe dozens or hund or hund
hundreds hundreds of either single
family homes or multif family homes is
that right that's right yes and then I'm
an investor in dozens of real estate
deals through as being an LP okay so you
that's your perspective that's my
perspective I'm you know in LP and a lot
of the people you know people would be
like did you unfollow me because of my
opinion out the Middle East crisis and
I'm like no I unfollowed you because
you're a fraud and you're pretending
like you're a good real estate investor
and you're a [__] complete criminal
and I know it because I'm an LP in your
business like you know even now I can
feel my blood boilet they're tweeting
out tweeting out their returns they're
like here are our returns and I'm like
these are not returns that I've realized
as an LP in your deal as an LP in your
businesses and you know they have the
audacity like you know I'll be like hey
uh we're like you know before interest
rates were going up I was like do we
have floating rate mortgages what the
[__] is going to happen when interest
rates go up and these guys are like uh
it's going to be fine it's it's going to
be fine and now they're like actually we
need more money and like you know uh
startups are one thing where you might
need more Capital as a business grows
because you're trying to expand for some
reason or another real estate is a
business where once you own the asset
you should not need more cash you're not
like expanding the real estate in any
way you're operating an apartment
building the problem is what happens is
when the interest rates go up and you
have more debt to pay every single month
because you're on a floating rate you
need more Capital to be able to pay that
debt because the rents don't service it
rents are going down interest rates are
going up and these guys who have
promised you know uh making fortunes are
like are caught with their pants down
and then what the which is crazy then
they have the audacity to say hey
actually where our returns are fantastic
then they the like the other audacity
that they have is they're like okay all
the deals you invested in with in the
last five years with us are bad because
interest rates are up but now we can buy
things at a lower price because prices
have gone down their interest rates are
up so buy with me now I'm a good now
it's a good time to invest with me and I
want to be like I want to [__] kill
you is really the answer um you know I
hate that type of [__] you said why
isn't anyone calling these people out um
yeah why aren't you calling them out
would you like to name some names we got
a great audience here that would love to
hear the names of some of these folks
yeah I don't want to name names because
I want them like you know some of these
people I'm friends with and I'm like I
know your wives and your families and I
don't want you to like suffer like I
don't want to see you sort of suffering
in that way you just want to kill them
but like yes I do want to kill them I do
think they're like
I I like there are very few people I
would ever invest again with in real
estate Twitter the one exception to that
rule I'll name the exception rather than
the rule itself is Moses Kagan where
I've invested in several deals with him
and I'm like this guy underwrites
conservatively like I underwrite um and
he's like thinking about the game in a
long-term way where he's like I want to
manage my reputation I want people to
make money I'll make money when people
make money and I would invest with him
again in a lot of other deals that I've
done with people on real estate Twitter
I'm like I would need uh you know I
would have have to be a heroin addict to
invest with you
again you said last time you were on the
podcast uh you did a pie chart um which
normally people do as percentages and
you did as dollars which I thought was
such a boss move and really enjoyed so I
want you to tell me how it's changed
since then so you said at the time this
was 2022 mid 2022 so it's been about a
year um since then a little more than a
year you said I got 10 million of in
private Equity 40 to 50 million in cash
which is short-term bonds I'm waiting
for bond prices to come up you said then
you said that was so
smart then you said 2530 million in real
estate um that we own and operate
ourselves and then 10 million in real
estate as a LP in other people's funds
he said 10 million in startup
Investments and 10 million in the stock
market um what do you has that changed
have you have you made shifts since then
in how you are investing yeah sure um
good question uh it hasn't changed from
atically um I would say the4 to $50
million in bonds is probably somewhere
at 60 to 70 today but it's still in
short-term bonds which you're yielding a
lot uh I'm starting to get a little bit
longer as like the yield curve starts to
flatten like right now if you buy a
one-year Bond you'll get about 5.5%
interest uh in a year if you buy a
10-year bond it's a little bit under
five uh you know a year ago it was like
five it was let's say 5% for a year but
4% for 10 years and now the the like the
curve was inverted and now starting to
flatten a little bit and as it continues
to flatten I invest in longer term bonds
rather than just short-term bonds uh I
probably have 15 to20 million in the
stock market at this point uh heavily
concentrated in Facebook and uh uh and
Shopify uh probably like and probably
PNG you tweet out this funny thing it
was uh your your IR versus uh S&P and
you're like uh you quoted you quoted
Legally Blonde you're like what like
Stock Investing is hard it's hard yeah
that's right
yeah and what was what was the returns
what was the comparison um yeah I was
probably up 30% for the era yeah versus
S&P was like three or something or or 10
12 or something like that yeah uh but I
you didn't say what you owned and in my
head I was like I bet that is literally
just Facebook Facebook yeah yeah it's
it's a lot of Facebook um Facebook and
Shopify and PG you and your brother kept
buying the dip like Facebook was getting
crushed like uh you know yeah I don't
know a year and a half ago to to like
you know up until six months ago or
something and um every time it went down
I remember your brother and I think you
also were like uh hey is everybody
insane uh great I can't wait to go buy
more Facebook today and the earnings and
psychologically it's hard right earnings
come out or or uh you know big stock
move happens goes down and to be like
all right woo let's go but let's buy in
more Buy in more that takes a totally
different mindset uh what's your what
drives the conviction because it's
obviously not a reaction to the you're
not reacting to momentum in fact you're
going you're betting against the current
momentum so what made you believe that
that's like a place that you wanted to
be investing um I would say two things
one is literally every single business I
know that's a online retailer is
entirely dependent on Facebook whether
they realize it or not like anybody any
look the best businesses in direct
consumer are entirely dependent on
Facebook the worst businesses are
Diversified and it's that simple if
you're entirely if you're like my
business lives or dies by Facebook I'm
like you're going to have a better
outcome than if you think your business
lives and dies by YouTube ads brick and
more actually brick and word is an
exception to that but like YouTube ads
I'm Diversified with my advertising
strategy I'm investing a lot in Tik Tok
that means you can't get the thing that
works for everybody and is the biggest
advertising engine in the world to work
for you you're going to miss out out a
ton of opportunity um and and so I'd say
that is one of them but like the reality
is and this is a little bit of a longer
story when the financial crisis hit my
father who had been conservative his
entire life he was probably like 70
years old at the time and he's like this
doesn't make sense how cheap these
houses are and so um he bought one house
and um it was probably like a, 1500t
house and he paid $150,000 for it and it
just sold for like 225 uh like you know
a couple months before and he's like
there's a $75,000 discount after 60 days
and then the 60 days later that 150 was
probably worth like
75,000 and rather than get scared and be
like oh [__] I lost $75,000 and we don't
have a lot of money at that time he's
like this doesn't make any sense uh now
this house over here that sold for $250
four months ago is for
$75,000 and so he kept purchasing real
estate and um you know there was one
half duplex that he purchased for
$88,000 and it generates like $1900 in
rent a month today like within uh you
know within a year we purchased back the
entire duplex every single year and uh
he never lost conviction he's like this
is a deal of a lifetime and uh I've got
the conviction that I'm right here and
you know honestly you know people talk
about my brother and I and how we've
like had financial success the reality
is that financial success is based on
the idea that we will not need a lot of
money in the future because he he
started purchasing real estate and
created a steady stream of income for
our family that would be very hard to
lose uh we had the benefit of that and
sort of the solid foundation of like not
worrying about money and sort of being
able to take a lot of risk because we
could fall back on real estate um and
that gave me a lot of conviction where
I'm like wow it it is possible to Buck
the trend here and say you know what
these people are wrong this like you
know this is on sale you're selling this
incredible asset and it's 50% off and I
know it because I'm looking at you know
25 ad accounts on a daily basis and
seeing that these people are still
investing ad dollars on Facebook um so
how could it be 25 how could it be 25%
off how could Facebook stock be 50% off
this is a buying opportunity not a
selling opportunity of your uh portfolio
now what percentage of it came from
native uh was did Native make up the
bulk of it and then it's just has grown
nicely since
then um I would say native is uh you
know it's hard to answer that question
because like n so when native sold uh
let's say I I made virtually the entire
amount um but that you know like that
the my netw worth is significantly
higher than that now but like you know
it's based on like you know I wouldn't
own $50 million in Bonds were it not for
the hundred million I got from native
sale so like yeah while the interest I
don't know if the interest is a able the
native or it is not presumably it is um
you know certainly if I were getting a
divorce and I didn't have a pre-op I'd
say all of this is native money like it
all came from native that's pre uh
pre-marriage uh and so um you know the
bulk of my uh Financial net worth as a
result of selling native but at this
point the cash itself from native is
probably less than a majority of my not
worth when you um you talk about like
you know 08 your dad saw that
opportunity underpriced when Facebook
stock is crashing you feel like this is
an underpriced asset um what do you feel
like are the kind of underpriced
opportunities or assets today I think
San Francisco real estate and possibly
office real estate in a lot of other
cities but I do think that like um that
like you know the the question is how do
you want to get in there um and when we
were when my father was buying this real
estate 08 I was in a it must been like a
little bit later actually must have been
like 2010 I was an attorney and all
these like wealth managers try and talk
to attorneys and so I was like look I
need a loan um for 500 my family needs a
loan for $500,000 we bought a million
dollar of real estate we just want 50%
LTV and Wells Fargo would be like the
only way we're going to give you a loan
is if you give us a million dollars in
cash then we'll give you a million
dollar loan and I was like I don't
understand if you guys know how money
works but if I had a million dollars in
cash I wouldn't come to you for a
[__] million dollar loan I wouldn't
give you that um but so anyway like we
were we were strapped for cash and try
to deploy it and then what my father did
is he dollar cost averaged into the real
estate State uh and he didn't know that
that's what he was doing he was just
like okay we got like another you know
$50,000 to spend let's go buy a house
and um he would get that $50,000 for
rent that he was collecting and so he
just dollar cost averaged his way in and
was really aggressive um I'm if if you
were dollar cost averaging your way into
office space I'd probably start you know
in 2023 or early very early 20224 if you
were like I'm trying to time the bottom
which is really hard to do correctly
obviously I'd probably still wait four
to 5 months cuz there's probably still
some uh you know some deals that have to
go that have to light on fire before the
rest of the world realizes okay my real
estate is not worth 100 million it's
actually worth 30 million today yeah I
agree with the San Francisco thing what
do you think what was your answer to
that question I didn't have an answer
but I wanted to know your opinion on
like uh some of these D Toc companies
that just got smashed in the stock
market so like you know an all birds
brand which I don't know what the market
cap is it's like $50 million or
something it's come down come way way
way down revenues over 100 million
market cap you know 50on today is 138
yeah no I think it has to go bankrupt
before you can touch that and why is
that they just totally mismanaged it or
it's too much debt or what's the problem
with that that business I I haven't
looked uh probably like real estate uh
is probably not good their team is too
large they might have some like
Financial Obligations probably to their
suppliers that are really holding down
their they have a lot of accounts uh
payable um and you need to wipe that all
out before you can get into it you know
I looked at this with honest as well and
I was like um I talked to some serious
people and I was like Hey I want to buy
I'm thinking about buying honest um and
uh that business was that business had
different problems that business had
gross margin problems which was they if
they sell a diaper for a dollar it
actually cost them 7 cents and generally
this industry you it actually cost you
like 30 cents you should have you know
60 70% gross margins these guys had 30%
gross margins so they they had a
different problem but like um I I think
with all birds it's a it's more severe
it's uh you know know it's systemic it's
a brand like you know it's a brand like
it needs I think it'll have to go
through bankruptcy in a little to be uh
fixed do you look at things like AI do
you pay attention to it or you just like
I'm a merchant I used to cash checks at
a gas station and I sold deodorant uh
you know through Facebook ads and now
you know I you know are you like real
estate you know the only things I can
touch and feel or do you pay attention
do you get swept up at all in the kind
of the crazes of the day like AI um I
think I get swept up a little bit but
I'm probably more cautious where I'm
like I want to see how this thing makes
money uh I remember our last podcast
Sean you were like how much do you have
in Bitcoin because that was one thing on
my pie chart I did not talk about and I
was like you know probably less than
$500,000 and today it's you know like
probably less than
$200,000 um you know I like to know how
I'm going to make money I guess I'm far
more risk averse than most entrepreneurs
um and that risk aversion means that I
probably won't invest in businesses
unless I have a good idea idea of like
how does this business make money or who
who purchases this business or how do we
how do we exit this business 5 to 10
years from now I need like a realistic
vision of that and if I don't have that
I'm probably less inclined to get behind
it and so I think that's made me shy
away from Bitcoin that's made me shy
away from AI probably to my own
detriment are you managing everything
yourself and what tools are you using is
it just a a sheet just an Excel sheet
yeah there's a Google sheet my brother
and I share where we're like here's your
investment like you know if it's a you
know here's a fund here's how much we
committed here's how much we've invested
if it's a startup it's here's how much
we put in do do you guys still have like
One bank account he told me once he was
like yeah it's kind of just like a
family pot of money I'm like how does
that work a little bit a little bit uh a
little bit yes uh is the honest answer
is yes still uh in in very many ways I
think the answer is yes to that um when
you see him buying something stupid
you're like you're spending our money
[__] what are you doing well I knew he
was going to buy you a gift one time and
I was like well he's kind of buying
himself a gift right you it's our money
uh you you don't like you don't like
wealth managers uh so do you manage
everything yourself CU that's a
full-time job almost that is a full-time
job if you want to be good at it and if
you don't get like if you don't want to
be good at it it's less of a full-time
job like at this point I'm I'm mostly
content with if I'm not making a startup
investment I'm generally going to think
of the S&P 500 or a US Treasury I'm not
like chasing the extra yield um where
I'm like if I put a lot of effort into
this instead of a US treasury maybe an
Uber like uber bonds that are dated in
2025 are paying
6.2% but you have to analyze what's the
tax implication of this Uber Bond versus
a US Treasury to to determine net yields
uh I'm not like that uh I'm just like
give me the US Treasury the extra 1%
yield isn't worth it I'll go make a
percent elsewhere um my wealth managers
I've been through a several now um I've
been through Goldman Sachs Goldman Sachs
you know uh I like Goldman Sachs is like
always consult us before you make an
investment we'll just give you a real
opinion and I did that for a while and I
was like okay I thought you guys were
just going to be like is this a good
idea or a bad idea but they're always
like no give us the money instead I I
used to tell the story I told I I told I
went to like my Goldman sachs's uh like
my wealth manager's boss I had to come
over to the native offices and I was
like look I believe that if I told my
wealth manager that Bill Gates was ready
to give me a billion dollars tomorrow if
I let him borrow this pen and he signed
a contract to that effect and put the
billion dollars in a briefcase and give
me that give me the briefcase you'd say
don't do that deal give us the pen
instead like uh they would not they
would like they would not let you loan a
dollar to Bill Gates if he was going to
give you a billion dollars tomorrow and
he prefunding dollars they'd say give us
the dollar we can do better with it U
let us earn fees on your dollar don't
take the billion dollars let us earn
fees and I told my Goldman Sachs wealth
manager's boss I was like this is how I
feel in your organization it is [__]
horrific um and uh you know I still feel
that way about them uh like you know I'm
still angry at them um and then I went
to this tell me how you really feel yeah
yeah I I'll tell them still one of the
funniest tweets I ever saw was you go oh
here's a photo of every uh 3pl owner
that I've ever seen and it was a picture
of the
hamburgler was so
funny was so funny oh my God and I
couldn't even imagine what you were
going through that would get you to the
point where you're like I'm GNA tweet
this out and where's what where's a
picture of the Hamburglar because that's
that's how clown clownishly criminal
these guys are with how they rip you off
uh so so funny my last wealth manager um
was like about a year and a half ago was
like you should invest everything into
uh bonds right now we think the FED is
going to engineer soft landing and
everything's going to be perfect and so
you want this three you'll get a 3%
yield if you invest in a 5year duration
so basically that you'll get 3% a year
but you have to commit to it without
money being invested for five years and
um so I put like uh I think it was like
five or 7 million to that and uh against
that strategy and then a quarter in like
probably three months later I was like
you know what I don't believe in this
sell everything right now I'm going to
take a loss I don't think we're going to
engineer this soft Landing interest
rates are going to go up inflation is 9%
the [__] are you guys thinking that we
could engineer soft Landing year with
with interest rates staying the same as
interest rates remaining the way they
are and inflation being nine [__]
per. you think that I should get a 3%
yield and so uh we sold the $7 million I
probably lost $150 or $125,000 or
$150,000 in that three-month period
doing this three months lost $150,000
because I bet against them and you know
people started to realize interest rates
would rise and uh since then I've just
invested in like you know 3 months six
month one-year treasuries um to take
take advantage of the yth and so like
you know these guy the guys who are the
wealth managers their job is not to
understand markets their job is is to
understand um how to sell you an asset
they're just car salesmen who sell like
you know financial instruments rather
than cars and they're like just as
Sleazy and just as like slimy and just
as charismatic as well and um you know I
trust you know have you seen like
Seinfeld where George castanza is in a
car dealership and a car dealer is like
walking towards him and he's like stop
right there otherwise I'm going to leave
that's whenever my wealth manager is
like let me sell you this asset I'm like
stop right there I'm going to hang up
the phone if we continue this
conversation vo or you know us
treasuries don't try and sell me
anything else I know how you guys think
are you ever going to start another
company again and and make that your
thing you missing it yes definitely um
you know I think that uh I can't turn
$100 million into a billion dollars uh I
can only start a business that sells for
a billion dollars so I think the answer
is yes in fact I'm certain hey what what
happened to the guy on Twitter who said
uh Hey money is not going to make you
happy uh it's your friend and your
family and your what did you what you
say you had some tweet about this the
other day that I was like you do you
have a Ghost Rider who who is this this
is not on brand this is not the guy who
said I was put on Earth to increase
earnings per share I like the old boys
the guy who was like it all be true it
all can be true right you could he wants
to get after it you don't have to do it
just to make you happy you do it just
because it's exciting and I think like
it all depends on the mood you're in
where you're like lonely or spending a
lot of time with friends and you're like
wow this is great and then you you know
I'll spend time with friends and this
guy will be like yeah I'm making I
started this director consumer business
I'm doing $100 million our second year
$20 million in iida and I'm like [__]
friendship I need to get that uh and so
I think it's all like The Grass Is
Always Greener um and so sometimes I'm
in the like you know I had this other
two where I'm like sometimes I want to
be like a warrior and U make a lot of
money and other times I want to be like
a civilian and um just spend time with
loved ones I don't have a good answer to
that I see a therapist and she doesn't
have a good answer to that for me either
hey no there's uh what is it sun Su it's
better to be a warrior in the garden as
opposed to a gardener in war so uh you
know you could still be this crazy
person and chill every once in a while
wow that is a great quote I've never
heard that before that's awesome what
are business ideas that you guys have
what are what's a business idea that I
should start you know if I want to start
a business what's what you guys talk to
a lot more people than I do what's a
business idea I should start well my
honest opinion is that you now have new
advant manages and so like you could
start a new business from scratch but I
really do think the thing you should do
is take a huge slug of capital buy
something that is like you know already
worth hundred million do like you could
you could take something from 100 to 500
or 100 to a billion much easier than
going from zero to 500 uh with like a
new product in the marketplace and so I
I think that's what I would that's where
I would start the process of thinking
thinking about I think you'd be very
successful doing that or or buying like
U I forget the guy's name natnat
something the guy who bought uh the
trading C company like like an old uh
what was it called Sean yeah net Turner
is that his name n Turner yeah he bought
like a trading car company and he's like
I'm gonna make this cool again I think
you would succeed doing that but my read
on you is that you are significantly
more of a Creator and an artist than you
want people to think and I think that
you have to because I I saw how like
careful you were about customer service
and about the brand and even though you
want to act like this tough guy like you
were like I'm going to answer
200 customer service emails and I'm
going to like Delight them and I
remember about the website like you act
like oh I just copied this I copied that
there's a lot more thought and care than
you than you give that Vibe out and so
if if if I had to tell you what to do it
would be uh start something from scratch
and make it art and then also have that
50% of you that you know only cares
about evid you know or whatever uh but I
I my opinion is of who you are is you
need to be a little bit more of artist
than you have lately I couldn't agree
more I appreciate that yeah I actually
agree with that I I also think uh what I
would not do is I would not do another
DDC brand even though you know how to do
it and you could do it like you know in
your sleep at this point um just because
you're playing the same level of the
video game that you you already beat and
like you know what's more valuable than
the money you would make in that is like
you have like certain number of years of
like you're you're in like Peak mental
physical like abilities right now and
like use those years wisely either go do
just the funnest things you can think of
you know around the world and travel and
do all that good stuff or if you are
going to do a creative project make it
one that like you know puts those to
good use and to good challenge you know
like if you if you came to me and you
said uh like you know I'm starting
another D Toc brand and it's going to be
um you know not deodorant but whatever
some other thing you know uh yeah I
would be like okay that's cool I'm sure
it's going to be successful but um I
don't think that's what will make you
more that's [__] because native
deodorant like I use the soap because
like I trust the brand like he built a
brand I mean it's a it's a trusted brand
uh partially because I know Moyes I
don't know the the owner now so I don't
I don't know actually if they're
sticking to what the prom you don't know
Proctor well I I don't know if they're
actually it's the opposite I think if
they own it they're probably going to
ruin it uh but like if you were to
create like some type of food that is a
healthy option or something baby formula
that's a healthy option I actually think
that that would start and look silly but
it actually has massive implications and
would make I don't like saying this but
it could make the world even a slightly
better place and you could find some
fulfillment in that uh and it would look
just like another Ecom brand but as long
as it's not like something stupid that
doesn't that doesn't matter to people
like for example another all Bird's
thing but something that I put in my
body uh you know or something that makes
my kid healthier something like that I I
I think that could fulfill you I
appreciate that and I appreciate that
inspiration as well I think there's uh
truth to both those things like I I want
to build build something bit like one of
the reasons that I haven't really gotten
excited about anything is cuz I want
something to be you know 10 times bigger
than my last business and that's um you
know that's hard to do and hard to be
excited about and hard to say you know
what I'm going to spend the next 10
years of my life building this business
um and that's uh you know that's what's
made me really cautious about it but in
a way that I think is um you know making
my mind less flexible than it was 5
years ago well you better get on it man
you don't want to be a hasband or a one-
hit wonder I I I I think that I think
that is only it's a home run for
everyone else I think it's a base hit
for you um but I'm I'm like every day
I'm like what's he doing what's he doing
is he doing it I'll see you tweet
something I'm like is that gonna be the
thing is that gonna be the thing is he
gonna actually call in you know you're
gonna be you're GNA be like Uncle Rico
bragging about how you almost took state
in high school like I want you know what
I mean that's right what a NE what an
amazing NE well hey look that's it's not
a NE I'm saying you're you know it's a
compliment look it's a compliment I
you're going to you're going to do great
things but whether you're going to
finally nut up and actually do it uh and
that's what I'm eager
for yeah yeah in fact my my banker from
the Native sale texted me yesterday and
he's like you know November 8th is the
six year anniversary of the sale and so
like it's been six years since I've been
out uh you know sold the business and
you know I think so far it's been my B
Opus good you want to feel some anxiety
today it's been six years you want to
[__] up your day here you go you know
what that is he's doing a home option
for investment banking he's like texting
me once in a while be like hey when it's
time to sell this your next business
don't forget about me I'm still texting
you what was the um what what's the
sales now of native I bet you that's
doing two or 300 million a year now
right 500 this year 500 oh could have
what have should have no I'm I'm joking
you I would have sold probably as well I
know I don't think I could have done
yeah I don't think I could have done
with PNG is done without that like
they've made it an amazing brand they
think about like um you know product
development they think about shelf space
they think about things in a way that's
really spectacular and I'm not to say
that there are things where I look at
them I'm like oo I wouldn't have done
that like I definitely see that once in
a while but ultimately like um you know
the reason that I sold what I did was I
wanted to learn from people who are
Masters at something about how to grow
something from you know 30 to 100 or 500
and I think I learned a lot of that
while I was there and so you know there
people are always like do regret it I
there's not a day that goes by where I
go to bed and I'm like man I shouldn't
have sold I'm always like that was the
right decision wrap up with this one
line that you told me um you you you
were saying uh you telling me about the
sale the sale process and they were like
so how are you going to expand and you
looked at them all dumbfounded I go are
and you go well can you write the words
native on a shampoo bottle how how about
on toothpaste can you write that okay
that's how you expand and that's exactly
what they've done I actually don't use
the deodorant but I use the soap you uh
the soap is my favorite you've even had
like Melissa's cupcake soap and and you
have all this other soap I I I love the
soap and so uh your uh the body wash is
that right the body wash yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah and your body wash and you um
your smartass reply was their strategy
and it worked so
congratulations like a guy in the back
just taking
notes yeah he's gonna call someone hey
guys can we write native on this
bottle can we do that it was bananas I
remember that right on uh Moyes thanks
for coming on man and we appreciate you
coming on thank you very much talk
[Music]
to